FRANK DRAKE: There are so many
stars, and so many of them
are similar to the
Earth that it's
just impossible that there is
not a lot of intelligent life.
And I say a lot, not
just a little bit.
ADITYA CHOPRA: Could
there be life elsewhere?
We don't yet know.
But astrobiology is
one way to do it.
MOLLY O'BEIRNE: We
use observations
from telescopes that
look at molecules
in the atmosphere of a planet.
Which molecules are
there actually relates
to what kind of different
biologies are there.
JAMES PARR: What
we're trying to do
is imagine what this broad
range of life could be.
Because it's not limited
to life as we know it.
RODD TALEBI: So what we're
using is Google Cloud
to help simulate as
much data as possible,
try to build from the thousands
of datasets that we have,
the single observations,
to the tens of millions.
ADITYA CHOPRA: Google Cloud
also knows how to see patterns,
how to connect the dots.
It knows how to link up
different ideas together.
And we want to do that
in astrobiology, perhaps
better than what a human
alone or a group of humans
might be able to.
JAMES PARR: This is the moment
where we really discover
whether we're alone or not.
SETH SHOSTAK: Hi, team.
Welcome to a live
stream here from Google
in Mountain View, California--
lovely, glamorous Mount
View, California in the
heart of the Silicon Valley--
or if not the heart, at least
somewhere behind the rib cage.
We're going to talk today
about something that you
probably don't think terribly
much about, but should,
and that's the interaction
of the cloud and science.
This may be the
future of science.
If you're doing science,
this is maybe your future.
In any case, I have with me
an expert on the Google Cloud
and how it interacts
with science.
Let me just tell you a couple
of sentences about myself.
My name is Seth Shostak,
and I'm a senior astronomer
at the SETI Institute, also here
in Mountain View, California.
And our job is to look for life
in space, and in particular,
whether there's any
intelligent life in space.
But we're going to talk about
that maybe a little bit later.
At the moment, I
want to introduce
our expert, Massimo Mascaro.
And Massimo, tell us a
little bit about yourself.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Nice
to meet everyone.
Yeah, my name is
Massimo Mascaro.
I'm a technical
director here at Google.
And actually, I work
specifically on applied AI.
I have a background in physics.
Actually, I was a space nerd
and an aspiring astrophysicist,
but then I got into
computational neuroscience.
I got kind of fulminated by
the idea of neural networks,
and I started working in AI.
And I've been doing that since.
Here at Google, I'm
in Google Cloud.
And what I do is that I work
with some of the largest Google
clients helping them applying
AI inside their problems.
So this is actually how I
came to work on this project.
Because about in
April last year,
we started working with NASA,
in particular the Frontier
Development Lab.
And at that point,
actually, I really--
my passion for space
kicked in, and I decided
to step in and work with them.
SETH SHOSTAK: OK.
Now, you talk about FDL.
That's the Frontier
Development Lab.
That's an initiative
of NASA, right?
MASSIMO MASCARO: It is.
SETH SHOSTAK: So how
does NASA interact
with the private sector?
Because Google, after all,
is in the private sector.
MASSIMO MASCARO: It is.
So FDL is a really, really
cool program that NASA runs.
What they do is they seek
partnership with, basically,
private companies to help out on
some of the biggest challenges
that NASA has.
One of the big themes that
FDL can research about--
and in fact, I would say is one
of the most prominent ones--
is actually artificial
intelligence applied
to NASA's problem.
So Google--
SETH SHOSTAK: Give me
an example of a problem.
MASSIMO MASCARO: For example,
one of the things, actually,
that we worked on
this year is actually
is a big problem
artificial intelligence.
How do you actually
automatically detect
transiting of planets
from the signals
that you get from
your space telescopes?
It is a problem
where, if you want,
machine learning is
very, very useful too.
Because right now,
actually, a lot of this
is done actually
manually by astronomers.
And actually, there is
high error rates in that.
SETH SHOSTAK: OK.
So in the cloud, you have,
of course, the opportunity
for sharing data.
Anybody can get
to it, presumably,
if they're interested in
the problem of looking
for planets around other
stars, just to follow up
on your example.
They can get to the data.
But they can get to
something else there too.
They can get the tools, right?
MASSIMO MASCARO: So
I think, actually,
three main things that
you can get in the cloud.
So the first one, of
course, is the ability
to get a lot of
data in and have,
actually, very, very
fast access to it.
That's actually
bread and butter,
and you have to have that.
The other thing is competition.
So on the cloud, you can
get a lot of computation
to run on top of that data.
And that actually is
also very important.
And this actually, by
the way, in science
is not a super easy thing
to do, believe it or not.
Some of the largest
supercomputers
today are used for science.
But actually, they're not
very available to a lot
of scientists.
And then the third
thing is in cloud,
actually, we built a
sequence of higher level
of things that allow
you to do things
from analytics and
data processing
to AI and machine learning.
There actually
are tools that you
build on top of these two
layers of data and computation
that allow you to do those
kind of things actually
much more easily.
SETH SHOSTAK: OK.
Now, suppose I'm a
research scientist.
I kind of know what
they look like.
There a lot of them
near my office.
They're sitting in their cubes.
They're sitting in
their offices, whatever.
And they're on a desk.
And in the corner,
there's a stack
of reprints that only
five people in the world
can actually understand.
And they're working
on a problem.
Maybe that problem
is exactly this one.
They want to know, are there
a lot of planets out there?
Are there not a lot
of planets out there?
OK.
Now, in the past, they would
have to go get some data
themselves, and they
would have exclusive use
of that data, at
least for a while,
even if it was from the Hubble
Telescope or some publicly
owned instrument.
And now, OK, they need
to go through those data
and take a look.
Is there something
interesting in it?
They'd write some
code themselves.
It would be proprietary.
They would probably
spend half their lives
debugging their own code.
And they would have
a limited dataset,
and that's how they would work.
How is that going to happen now?
I'm sitting in my
office wondering, hey,
look, how am I going to beat
all those competitors out there?
MASSIMO MASCARO: So
a couple of things.
Of course, scientific
data very often
actually come from sources
like what you mentioned.
So for example, I can tell you
that in the work that we've
been doing with
FDL on exoplanets,
we'd be working
with Kepler's data.
That is now actually
a public dataset.
But there is a delay, because
there are certain research
institutions that usually have
exclusiveness on those data.
For example, we haven't worked
yet on the newly test data.
So for those who
don't know, Kepler
is the old exoplanet
source satellite.
SETH SHOSTAK: Old.
It's been dead
for what, a month?
MASSIMO MASCARO: A month.
But actually, it's been actually
in space for 10 years or more.
And TESS is just newly launched.
They launched it with
SpaceX last April.
And TESS actually is in orbit,
and it's collecting data.
But that data is
not available yet.
It is available to NASA
and to some of the research
scientists, but
not to the public.
So two things actually there.
Of course, you have to
have access to the data.
But very, very large datasets
are now becoming public.
And in any case,
it's always possible,
even if you have private
datasets, to work with Google
and have it imported in a
private setup inside the cloud.
The cloud doesn't have
to be public in that it's
open to everyone if
you don't want to.
We have a lot of, if you
want, commercial customers
that have very, very sensitive
data they do not share.
So that's possible.
But I would say that the very
exciting thing is when you
work on these public datasets.
And now, actually, you
have access to these data.
But very often, having
access to the data--
I can download all the
Kepler sets from NASA
today if I want to.
But the point is that what
am I going to do with it?
Because first of
all, it's likely not
going to fit inside my computer.
And even if it does, then
actually processing that data
requires very extensive
computational capabilities
that I wouldn't have.
And the cloud allows
you to have those
at a very, very cheap price.
Now, in the work, actually, with
NASA, Google sponsored that.
So that was not an issue.
But in general, even if somebody
had to pay it, it's actually--
you only pay for what
you use, actually.
Google actually will charge
you by the second, literally.
When you have a
machine, if you have it
for 1 minute and 37 seconds to
do a particular computation,
that's exactly what
you'll get charged for.
And so this actually is very
transformative, I think,
in science.
Because now I have these
very large data sets
that are becoming more
and more available.
I have the ability to spawn,
with a very, very cheap price,
very large competition
to analyze the datasets.
And now I have this
whole layer of toolings
that, for example, allow me to
create a machine learning model
or to run a very
sophisticated analysis
that before actually
would have required
me to get an extra time slot
on a very big supercomputer
that maybe, actually,
my department
doesn't have access to.
So this really allows
everyone to do this.
And I would actually
put it even beyond that.
There are actually
a lot of initiatives
right now around
citizenship science,
people that are not
officially scientists
starting to do real science.
And I think, actually,
this opens up
a lot the floodgates of
that to happen as well.
SETH SHOSTAK: What
I was going to say--
this sounds like taking
citizen science to the max.
Right?
Because now everybody
can get to the data.
But beyond that, everybody
has some very competently
written, presumably,
tools to allow
them to look at that data.
So they can look for
correlations, or they--
presumably, they
could say, OK, what
I want to find is some sort of
dip in the brightness of stars
that tells me that that star
has some planets going around,
whatever it is.
Can you give me another
example of the kind of things?
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yeah.
And actually, this
is another example
that we worked on this summer
that is also opening up
another stream of thought.
In the second work
we did with NASA,
we were working on astrobiology.
And one of the big problems
in astrobiology is--
OK, assuming there are
planets out there-- and now,
we know actually that there
are many exoplanets out there
outside of our solar system.
We want to know actually
whether there's life or not.
The problem of knowing
whether there's life or not
is to also understand
what life is.
There are many, many different
kinds of possible life
that would be conceivable.
In a sense, actually,
we only have
one sample, what is on Earth.
So one way around this is
that you could simulate
what life could look like.
And there are
actually various ways.
The thing, actually, that
we did with FDL this summer
was to basically simulate
metabolic pathways,
so different combinations of
molecules that bond chemically.
SETH SHOSTAK: Well, I've
got to follow up on this.
Because you can simulate
what extraterrestrial life
might be like.
Now, look, I get called up every
third week by some producer
down in Hollywood,
and they're going
to make a film about
how aliens come
to Earth to destroy
downtown Chicago
or whatever is on their minds.
And they want to know what are
the aliens going to look like.
Now, it sounds like you've got
the tools to figure that out.
Surely, that's not
exactly what you mean.
MASSIMO MASCARO: No.
It's much less
glamorous, if you want.
But actually, in a sense, it's
also much more interesting.
A lot of what we're
thinking about life today
in terms of humanoid
figures and so on--
we can actually go
there, but it's likely--
it's actually going
to be very unlikely.
The vast majority of life that
we expect to find on exoplanets
may be just unicellular, or
it maybe not even cellular.
Maybe it would be some
kind of chemical processes
that go on that signal the
fact that there is actually
something that can
be self-reproducing.
SETH SHOSTAK: OK.
So in other words--
to begin with, the whole
question of what life is--
that's a different
question, right?
And there's actually
no good answer to that.
People say, oh, life reproduces,
and metabolic processes,
all that stuff, uses
resources, maybe moves around.
But that's true of a lot
of physical phenomena
that are not alive, like
fire or something like that.
So in fact, it's not that
you're trying to define life.
You're trying to say,
what chemical processes
might lead to something that
has the characteristics of life?
Right?
Is that it?
MASSIMO MASCARO: It is.
And in a sense,
actually, it's actually
a restrictive idea of life.
Because there may be many, many
larger ways of intending it.
Life could be
completely digital,
or it could be actually not even
based necessarily on chemistry.
But in the realm of life
that is based on chemistry,
one thing that we know--
at least on Earth--
that life does is
that it changes
the chemical
compositions of planets.
In particular, it changes
the chemical composition
of atmospheres of planets.
And the reason
this is interesting
is that we have a shot at
measuring the atmospheres
of some of these exoplanets.
Now, to be clear, today
we cannot do that yet.
At least that's what my
NASA friends tell me.
But in the near future--
apparently, the
James Webb Telescope
may be able to do this.
We may be able to detect spectra
of some of these exoplanets.
SETH SHOSTAK: OK.
Just to clarify for people
who don't work in this field,
if you were to look at
Earth-- if you were a Klingon
astronomer--
I hope they get paid better
than the earthly kind.
But if you were a
Klingon astronomer
and you had a big enough
telescope, sort of like James
Webb, and you looked at
the Earth with that thing,
you might be able
to find that there's
oxygen in the atmosphere.
20% of the air in
this room is oxygen.
But that oxygen comes
from photosynthesis.
So they would say,
oh, I don't know
what's there, Zork,
but all that oxygen,
there must be lettuce or
asparagus or something
that does photosynthesis.
OK.
But that might not be
the only indicator.
Maybe they don't
breathe out oxygen
if they're plants
on another planet.
Is that the idea?
MASSIMO MASCARO:
That's the idea.
And the one thing I want to
say for people who are not
in this field is that you
could actually say, well,
couldn't oxygen just be on
that planet for other reasons?
Well, we know that oxygen binds
a lot to a lot of chemicals.
It's very unlikely
that oxygen stays
in the atmosphere
for a long period,
because it would
just oxidize most
of the stuff that is in that
planet and basically bind--
so basically disappear
from the atmosphere.
SETH SHOSTAK: It would turn
all the iron and the soil
to rust, like Mars.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Mars
is a good example.
So the fact that there is
oxygen is because something
is actively producing it.
Now, there are various ways in
which oxygen could be actively
produced by known life systems.
But we're not sure of
a lot of metabolic ways
in which this happens.
And actually, oxygen,
to your point,
is not just the only thing.
In fact, one of the
things they told
me, the astrobiologists
that we worked this year,
is that actually,
in a sense, oxygen
is almost like the
smoking gun of life.
Because an oxygen level like
the one that we have on Earth
is almost unlikely
to be actually
just due to geological sources.
But there are many
other chemicals.
For example, just looking at
the ratio of methane and oxygen
or methane and other
components, sulfur,
there are a lot
of other chemicals
that could actually
manifest signatures of life
being on the planets.
But going back to cloud
and what the problem is--
very often, these digital
signatures of what
would be the relative
components of these chemicals
in atmospheres, we only
know them for Earth.
And if you want to know what
the signature would look
like for different reasonable
metabolic pathways,
you would have to simulate that.
And this actually is
what we did with Google.
And one thing--
again, going back
to the initial discussion,
one thing that was very useful
is the fact that these
simulations are very expensive
computationally.
And in a sense,
actually, it would
take years to run
those things on even
very, very fancy hardware
that a normal university has.
We were able to spin up,
on Google Cloud, thousands
of machines in parallel.
And basically, the bulk of
the dataset that was produced
was produced in a matter
of a couple of weeks
by just actually spawning a
lot of machines inside our data
centers.
SETH SHOSTAK: I've
got to say, Massimo,
because I know somebody--
well, Sara Seager
is her name-- she's
at MIT, and this
is her job is to
try and figure out,
OK, if we can
measure whatever is
in the atmosphere, some
planet around some other star,
can we say that there's life
there, there's not life there?
Are people like that
using the Google Cloud?
Are they are already
using these tools?
Or is this coming down the
pike in the near future?
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yeah.
I think, actually,
it's picking up.
So I know that there are a
number of research institutes
and scientific institutions
that are already using Google
Cloud and cloud in general.
I think, actually,
one of the things
we did at NASA today,
at least this summer,
and that I'm actually
really hopeful that
will create some
movement, is the fact
that we proved how
this can be useful.
Now, one other aspect of the
NASA FDL program to get clear
is that it's a program
that lasted about 10 weeks.
So there are the scientists
that come and work
at actually FDL here
in Mountain View.
And in 10 weeks, they just have
to start and end and literally
have to finish their
technical reports in 10 weeks.
And so one other thing
I want to throw in there
is that it doesn't take much.
These guys literally arrived.
They had absolutely no knowledge
of the Google Cloud at all.
I remember, actually, we had
actually a meeting at Google,
and we were busy explaining
how to speed up machines,
how to train machine
learning models.
And there were-- most
of them actually had
absolutely no prior experience.
And they went,
actually, in 10 weeks
to publish some very
interesting results.
And actually, now they're
talking at conferences,
they're publishing
papers on this.
SETH SHOSTAK: All right.
So what you're saying is
scientists who are already
doing this, or scientists
who want to do this,
they're not going
to have to spend
years learning how to do it.
They can get trained up
in a couple of weeks,
and they can start
doing something useful.
MASSIMO MASCARO: I think so.
And I think, actually,
this is transformative.
Because at the end of the
day, a lot of modern science
is not anymore
just genius people
sitting down with paper and pen
and having a brilliant idea.
A lot actually has to
do with data analysis,
with computation,
with simulation.
And I think, actually,
cloud can be transformative.
Now, this actually-- still
we haven't touched yet
even into the realm of
machine learning and AI.
I think it's also very, very
interesting and exciting.
But one thing is just actually
at the basic of science,
I think, actually cloud
can be very transformative.
And I think it's just a matter
sometimes of culture and being
used to.
A lot of researchers today
do not know yet these tools.
They haven't experienced them.
And in a sense,
actually, I'm pretty
sure that as soon as they
get to know them better, then
they can change a
lot how they work.
SETH SHOSTAK: Let me take
another specific example here.
In the 1970s, NASA sent a couple
of Landers, the Viking Landers
to Mars looking for life on our
little ruddy buddy up there.
And the answer that came back--
this cost a lot of money.
It was like $1
billion or something.
I don't remember exactly.
But the answer that came
back was, don't know.
We don't think we
found any life.
But of course, we
can't be 100% positive.
Well, obviously,
the space agency
wasn't really happy
with this answer.
And I suppose the taxpayers,
to the extent that they
paid attention, weren't
very happy either.
Because you spent
all this money.
You want to know if
there's life on Mars.
It comes back maybe.
You don't want that.
You want a definitive
answer, like 42 or something.
You want a definitive answer.
Now, if they had had the
Google Cloud and these tools
back in the mid-1970s,
do you think
they would have had a better
answer in the sense of a more
definitive answer?
MASSIMO MASCARO: I don't
know, because actually, that's
actually whether the answer
was in the data or not.
So what the cloud cannot give
you is answers that are not
in the data.
That said, I think that
for a long time in science,
we've actually experienced
this idea that people
work on a particular problem.
They do an experiment.
Let's say you send a NASA probe,
or actually, sometimes you
do an experiment in a lab.
You collect a lot of data.
You process that at the
best thing which you can.
And actually, you publish a
paper, maybe, and that's it.
That's the end of that data.
I think, actually, the
idea that this data has now
become public, and these
data sets are becoming big,
and that people now from
all over the scientific and
non-scientific community can go
there and look at those data,
it means we can now start
squeezing much more information
out of the same datasets.
And actually, we can both
validate better our research
result, and we can also--
if you want to find things that
actually had gone undiscovered.
Case in point--
Kepler data.
Kepler has been
there for 10 years.
And with the help of Kepler,
NASA has been able to declare--
I don't remember
the number, but I
think, actually, it's north
of 2,500 planets, exoplanets
if I remember correctly.
SETH SHOSTAK: A
little more actually.
A lot.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Last
year, actually, Google
took that dataset--
and this is not
part of this FDL.
This was Google Brain, our
AI research department.
Took that data set,
and they basically
applied machine learning to it.
And they did discover
a number of exoplanets
that had gone undiscovered.
In fact, they discovered
an entire exoplanet system
that looks quite like the
Earth that have completely
gone undiscovered.
Now, on one side is the ability
to have access to the data.
So that's very important.
And I think, actually.
NASA is doing an
excellent job in making
all those datasets public.
And I think a lot of other
institutions, and even
university labs, should
just follow suit.
And some are, but even more.
Every dataset, in my
opinion, in science,
especially if it's publicly
funded, should be public.
But then that's not
sufficient either,
because now I have
this gigantic dataset,
and there is no way,
if I don't have access
to the NASA supercomputer,
I can actually
extract information from it.
So the idea that now,
actually, as somebody--
the guys at Google
actually-- this
was done, actually,
with an astronomer
at the University of Texas,
if I remember correctly.
But the other guy
actually here at Google
was just an AI engineer.
And they basically sat
down together and said,
OK, let's re-analyze this.
And they found exoplanets
that got missing.
So I think, actually this is
a great opportunity for us
to extract more information
out of the datasets that
are very often
costly we collect,
and actually tools to understand
better what's sometimes
actually wrong.
Because maybe sometimes,
actually, the problem
is that an analysis that
is being done actually
may be wrong.
And the idea that other
people can look at the data
actually makes it
much more verifiable.
That is actually one of
the principle of science.
SETH SHOSTAK: OK.
There are, coming down the pike,
some really big telescopes.
We're talking about
astronomy here a lot.
MASSIMO MASCARO: That's nice.
SETH SHOSTAK:
Well, that's right.
There can be telescopes that
can look at the entire sky
every four days,
that sort of thing,
see things that we've
never seen before.
There could be flashing
lights in the sky.
We would never see them because
the telescopes are never
looking in the right
place at the right time.
So we're going to have
instruments that can do that.
We're also building
these huge telescopes
with mirrors that are
20, 30 meters across.
And obviously, they're going
to be able to do things that
our current telescopes can't.
So the instrumentation is
certainly getting a lot better.
But it produces enormous
tons, mountains of data
that nobody can go
through anymore.
This is not like in the old
days when I was a kid just
before the Crimean War.
When I was a kid, you
would go to the telescope,
you would put a photographic
plate at the back end of it,
you'd make a photograph,
and then that plate
would go in your desk drawer.
Nobody else could get to it.
Nobody else could look at it.
And maybe you didn't
even look at it.
So obviously, that's
going to change.
It sounds like the
researchers are going
to become data scientists.
MASSIMO MASCARO: I, think,
actually, more and more--
I think, actually, in
part, they already are.
If you think about how--
most of the research
I have done,
personally, was really at the
border between data science,
data analysis, and actually--
in my case, I was
studying neuroscience.
I was trained to understand
how the brain works.
But it was a lot of
heavy data analysis.
But the other aspect is that
these datasets, to your point,
are becoming more
and more gigantic.
And they actually-- they are
more and more complex too.
Because some of these
telescopes require
you to do all sorts of
processing to these data,
and this processing
may sometimes
actually change the data.
So sometimes, you have to do
different kinds of processes.
And this actually was the
case of Kepler, for example.
And so the idea
that you have now
this vast computational
infrastructure,
this vast analytic
infrastructure-- and then
actually, we can
talk a little bit
about machine learning as well,
because I think, actually,
that's also going to
play a huge role there.
I think, actually, that's
going to be transformative.
Now, one last thing,
actually, on this point
is the fact that I
think more and more,
we're also starting to see data
collection happening outside
of the [INAUDIBLE],,
gigantus kind of instruments
that, let's say, NASA or
[INAUDIBLE] actually deploys.
There is an interesting
project that I
got to know about
where actually, they
put actually this small
telescope-- kind of almost
amateurish telescopes--
basically all around the globe
to track these exoplanets.
And the idea is
that TESS will only
look at a certain patch of
the sky for 28 days at a time.
And so maybe actually
the other telescopes
will pick up from that
and start doing this.
And again, this actually
[INAUDIBLE] datasets.
And it becomes
really fundamental
now to be able to
go across datasets--
not just being able to apply
the big guns of supercomputers
or the cloud into
particular datasets,
but being able to spawn between
datasets that very often have
very different shapes,
forms, and they
need very different kind of
pre-processing and ability
to parse.
So that actually is also--
going across datasets is going
to be very transformative.
SETH SHOSTAK: Well, I have
to say, in my line of work,
you're looking for a radio
signal or a light signal
coming from ET.
And we get lots of signals.
It's not like in
the movies where
you're sitting around
and looking bored,
and suddenly you see
a spike on a screen,
and everybody jumps up, and
starts screaming, and calling
up the press, and all that.
What actually happens is every
10 seconds, you get a signal.
But those signals can
be very messy-looking.
And AI might be just the ticket
to sort through those millions
and millions of signals
you're getting every day
and decide, OK,
this is interference
from the satellite.
This may be ET.
This is not ET,
that kind of thing.
Personally, this sounds like
a very attractive thing.
We've been talking a lot about
astronomy and space research.
Can you give me another example?
I'm just thinking there must be
huge datasets out there which
talk about various diseases.
People get a certain kind
of cancer, and this is--
maybe their diets or their
lifestyle or something else,
and nobody has
the ability to see
if there's a slight
correlation with maybe eating
broccoli and getting
cancer of the elbows
or something like that.
You know what I mean?
MASSIMO MASCARO: Those are
actually are big topics.
You may have heard
Google actually
is very vested into health.
And we're working a lot in it.
Actually, very
recently, we created
a whole division called
Google Health that
will work on those problems.
Some of the early
results in that area
are mind-boggling in that
it's not only about the fact
that you can now actually
infer across very, very
large datasets and
understand this is better.
It's the fact that
very often, you
then actually get
also diagnoses that
are much more democratized.
So to give you an
example, one of the work
that Google is doing is
to basically understand
from images of the eye,
of your retina, whether--
basically, they look
at your blood patterns
there and then can
infer whether you
have certain kinds of diabetes.
Now, this is transformative.
Because if you can do
this for real-- and this
is actually still
very experimental,
and it still has to
be a lot verified.
But if you can start doing this
with a camera on a smartphone,
that means that
somebody that is,
let's say, in a poor
region of the world
and hasn't access to super
good health systems and doctors
would just be able to
point his phone at his eye
and know something very, very
important about his health.
It also, of course--
even in rich countries where
we have access to health care,
it means much easier prevention.
I think that's going to
change a lot of things.
Now, going back to
the problem-- again,
you can do this if you can
actually build systems that are
able to very often
understand the minute--
very subtle kind of patterns
inside images, datasets,
temporal streams, what not.
So that's actually
where, very often, you
need to do very extensive
machine learning
on very large datasets.
Because in order for you
to detect those patterns,
you have to be able to identify
those patterns into very large
datasets [INAUDIBLE] again.
SETH SHOSTAK: So this brings to
mind a couple of possibilities.
One is in the diagnosis realm.
I am fortunate I live
here in California,
and if I don't feel well,
I can go to my physician.
And he's seen me for years.
And since I walk
into his office,
he already has made
some analysis of me
because he knows what I should
look like, that kind of thing.
But I think it's
already the case--
there have been
some demos of this--
that if you let the AI do the
analysis or the diagnosis,
that it might be a
little more accurate
than the human physician
because it doesn't forget all
those rare conditions that the
physician has because they've
never seen them.
So there is that.
And then there's the
question of-- indeed,
if you're in a part of the world
where you don't have access
to that kind of
health care, maybe
your phone, which
allows you to maybe do
some of these measurements--
send that to the AI,
and then it diagnoses
you, and you get
a better level of health care.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Again, this
is still very early times,
and this is actually still very
much in the domain of research
and science.
But I think,
actually, this is one
of the transformations that's
going to happen in health care.
I do agree with you that
very often, actually, today,
health care--
while we have wonderful doctors,
and the health science actually
has improved as we probably
could never have dreamed,
even like 20, 30 years ago--
I actually-- we know
that there are actually
a lot of differences
between doctors.
And the fact that a doctor is
a human person, a human being,
is a factor right.
Your doctor may have himself
a health issue the day
before he's visiting you.
And maybe he's not actually
completely at his best.
Or he just actually may
have a worry, because--
I don't know-- had an
argument with his son
the night before visiting you.
And again, that's
one issue with--
SETH SHOSTAK: Will they
have a good bedside manner?
That's a question you
probably get all the time.
I like my doctor because
he jokes around with me.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yes.
But actually, what I'm saying
is that machine learning is
completely extracted from this.
If you have a machine
learning that works,
it will work in a
very consistent way.
So that's [INAUDIBLE].
But of course,
actually, we don't
have yet holistically
machine learning
systems that can even get
close to match current doctors.
But that actually is
where a lot of research
is going right now, because
it is going to transform
completely the field.
Now, going back to
science, the part ahead
of the doctor giving you a full
diagnosis being driven by AI,
I think it is actually
doing a lot of research
into applying AI to medicine.
And it goes into this discussion
we're having about science.
Because those AIs
always come from you
having churned
through a lot of data
and having matched
whatever the AI is--
in this case predicting or
diagnosing with what you know
is true.
And actually, this
requires a lot
of work in actual basic
science to start with.
SETH SHOSTAK: We're getting
some questions from the viewers.
And here's one.
Could you explain the
usage of the Google Cloud
tools in the context of the
NASA Frontier Development Lab
for its challenges, which are
in the fields of exo and astro?
So you might want to explain
what exo and astro are, but--
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yeah.
So those were the two things,
actually, we touched on.
So exo is our exoplanet
search work with FDL
where we were basically trying
to train machine learning
algorithms that would detect
exoplanet passage into the data
from Kepler and then test.
And [INAUDIBLE],,
the astrobiology
work-- it really was
two streams of work.
One stream was about simulating
these metabolic pathways
to understand what,
again, life could
look like on these exoplanets.
And then the second
part was simulating
how those metabolic
pathways would
affect the spectrum
that you would--
the spectrum basically is
the different colors that you
basically see, the different
frequencies of light
that you see as light passes
through the atmosphere.
And when you actually
have that phenomenon,
you can actually detect
what kind of chemicals
are inside the atmosphere.
Of course, there is a lot that
goes on inside this process.
And so what is in the
atmosphere doesn't correlate one
to one, what the
spectrum looks like.
So the second part was
really characterizing
this light signature
as basically a spectrum
of planets.
So going to the question--
the tools, actually, that we
use were very wide-spanning.
So on one side, actually, we--
as I said, actually,
we had, actually,
all the data come
into Google Cloud.
We actually spawned
a lot of competition.
So a lot of the simulations have
been run inside Google Cloud.
We took some very, very
sophisticated codes
that actually NASA
had developed--
for example, simulating
atmospheres--
and we basically adapted
them to run on Google Cloud.
And then we run them at
very, very large scales.
Then the second part is that
those machine learning models
actually had to be
built. So on the machine
learning side, a lot
of the researchers
actually use
extensively something
that is becoming very, very
popular in data science
and in general research--
the ability to write notebooks.
Now, for those of you
who are not technical,
a notebook is
basically a document
where you can basically
put code and execute in it.
And you can actually
have graphics being
done inside that document.
So we had, actually,
a system that
would allow our researchers
to spawn their notebooks
inside our
infrastructure and run
machine learning through that.
Also, Google actually
provides a number of tools
to do what is called
serverless training.
That is, you can basically
submit a piece of code
to Google Cloud
and basically say,
these are my algorithms
that I need to train.
And that's actually
where the data is.
And this service that is called
Machine Learning Engine--
ML Engine for friends--
will basically take this code
and automatically train it
by actually spawning
the necessary machines
on the back end.
So this was very useful,
because again, you
don't have to care about how
many machines I have here
or there and actually
spawning up the machines
with the right environment.
So these actually were
the main basic tools.
Now, of course, as part of
this, those researchers--
and actually, this
is actually one thing
I care a lot in terms of
people understanding--
they've loaded into Google
Cloud a lot of open source
code and scientific libraries
that they found useful
for their work.
And this actually
is the cool thing.
You don't have to
think about, OK, I
have to do this work
on Google Cloud,
so I'm going to let go all the
tools that I'm familiar with
and get to learn all
these other tools.
And maybe Google Cloud is
not made for astrophysics
or clinical research.
SETH SHOSTAK: It doesn't
involve a complete reset
of your career.
MASSIMO MASCARO: No, not at all.
SETH SHOSTAK: OK.
And then let me ask you--
because obviously,
people want to know--
OK, this sounds great.
Can you point to some
concrete results?
Has the Google Cloud
published a paper?
Is the Nobel Prize
Committee calling up?
Maybe the cloud is going
to get to go to Sweden.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yeah.
So first of all, one thing
I actually want to make sure
is clear is that these
were actually researchers
working for this program.
And actually, they are actual
researchers that work in--
very often in universities.
They're usually postgraduate
students, or postdocs,
or some assistant professor
that was mentoring.
So as Google Cloud, where
I'm going to publish a paper,
those researchers will
be-- and there are a few,
actually, that are
coming down the line.
In terms of concrete
results, I'll
mention a couple of things.
The first one is that on
the exoplanet research,
the team actually was
able to train a model
to recognize those planets
inside the Kepler datasets.
And then actually, we simulate
the dataset for tests.
So again, as I said
at the beginning,
we don't have yet the test data,
so we couldn't run it there.
But we simulated a
dataset from TESS.
NASA has a very, very
sophisticated simulation
of what TESS data
would look like.
And they were able to
train a model on that that,
on one side, is more accurate,
at least in percentages,
than what we know
are the accuracies
from the previous models that
have been attempted, including
the one from Google AI that
I was mentioning before,
and including, actually,
the human performance that
is currently estimated
that is astronomer
looking at that data.
So the model was more accurate.
And I think, actually, that
was, of course, a great result.
But to me, actually even
more exciting-- the model
ended up being a couple
of orders of magnitude
smaller than the previous
attempts of models.
That is, ti's a
very small model.
It's very compact.
And what this allows
is now actually
to consider running this in
line with data collection.
Because before, actually,
a lot of those models
were pretty heavy, and they
required a lot of computation.
So they couldn't have been
run as the data arrived.
Being able to run a
model as data arrives
opens up a number
of possibilities.
For example, what I mentioned
before-- if there is actually
a particular
detection on test data
as the dataset is
getting streamed,
it means you can now alert other
telescopes or other researchers
about that potential detection.
And that means actually
collecting other data
from other sources that
could confirm or deny
that particular planet, or maybe
extract other characteristics.
One of the things that I
mentioned the beginning
is that TESS actually
will only look
at a pattern of the
sky for 28 days.
One limitation of
this-- and this
actually is not completely
true, because there
is a patch where they look
actually for an entire year.
But in those
patches, you only get
to see planets that have
very, very short orbits.
Because the planet
has to go around.
SETH SHOSTAK: Inner planets.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Exactly.
And sometimes, actually,
you could see a transit.
But then you don't get
to see the second transit
as it comes around, because
it's taking too long.
But this actually could be
great candidates, for example,
for NASA to now say, hey, we
have these potential candidates
of planets.
We don't know, A, whether
they're real planets or not,
B, how long actually it will
take to retransit again.
And maybe we can have, again,
citizen science, maybe,
or other telescopes, or other
researchers take on that
and augment the test datasets.
SETH SHOSTAK: Clearly, this
is kind of revolutionary.
Maybe I should excise
the words "kind of."
This revolution-- it seems
that we're at the beginning.
We've opened the door
to a whole new way
of analyzing data and learning
things about the cosmos
and about nature in general.
Have we reached a tipping point?
This is philosophical.
But do you figure that
500 years from now, people
will look back at the
beginning of the 21st century
and say, the most important
thing that happened
then was not reality television
or anything like that?
It was the beginning of AI
applied to real world problems.
MASSIMO MASCARO: I think,
actually, this is really--
we're at a tipping point where
this actually may happen.
I could actually tell you that.
Again, I'm working in AI in
a much broader, if you want,
spectrum of things
than science itself.
AI is changing a lot
of the way in which we
think about problems.
And science is one
of the problems
that we as humans
think of, probably
one of the most important
ones, because it's
about understanding our
universe and ourselves.
But AI is really at a tipping
point where, if you want,
it's now starting to lead
to results where we can now
solve problems in a
very, very different way.
Now, for science in particular,
I think going back--
I don't know in 500
years, but by going back,
we could really see that
starting from the '90s and then
in the last two decades,
more and more, if you want,
computers are being
applied to science.
They go back-- the initial
computers were almost
developed for science.
But now, actually, it
is becoming so prominent
that the idea of doing
science without computers
is completely
preposterous today.
And I think, actually,
in a few decades,
it may be that the idea of
doing science without AI
would be as preposterous as
today is the idea of doing
science without computers.
SETH SHOSTAK: But what
about doing science
without the scientists?
How far can this go?
MASSIMO MASCARO:
So this actually
is an interesting point.
[INAUDIBLE] actually
enacted on this.
So during one of the final
technical reviews that we had
with the Frontier
Development Lab, with FDL,
who are actually a number
of NASA researchers
and [INAUDIBLE], and we were--
the teams actually
were showing some
of those results made with AI.
And there were actually
a lot of questions about,
well, if this AI is
predicting-- so for example,
there was one study about
predicting solar activity where
they would actually be
able to predict much
better than the physical models
that the scientists had created
for that.
And one question is that-- well,
this thing is predicting better
than we are doing,
but it's not really
explaining what is going on.
And at the end of
the day, in science,
we want to understand
the mechanism.
We want to understand
the physics behind it.
So I think, actually, the--
at least in the spectrum
of what we know today,
of what the AI is
doing, there is
a lot of space for scientists.
Because eventually, these tools
will simulate a lot of data,
may actually be able
to detect patterns,
may be able to, if you want,
refine datasets in ways
that we're not able to do
as scientists, as humans.
But at the end of the
day, we also want to--
science is really about
understanding the why,
really going back
to that physical law
or understand the mechanism.
SETH SHOSTAK: Well, you're
talking about insight here.
Newton didn't have
AI working for him.
He had his brain.
And it turned out
that was good enough
to understand many of the-- but
he didn't have huge datasets.
He didn't-- he had
very limited datasets.
Now, let take a field such as--
well, you know a lot about,
and that's neuroscience.
They said the most complex
thing in the universe
is the human brain.
This may be an insult to the
Klingons, but who's to say?
And I suppose that at the
very small level where
you have individual neurons
and so forth, and synapses
and all that stuff, that you
might understand the chemistry.
You might understand the physics
of what's going on there.
But that doesn't mean that you
understand how thinking works,
because that's very complex.
This sounds like a
perfect application
of this new technology.
But will it provide, indeed, the
understanding of what happens?
Or does it just give you a
model, and you just input
a lot of data, and now you can
tell what the next thought is?
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yeah.
So this goes to what
I was saying before.
That is, right now,
actually, you could--
there are applications of
AI, believe, in neuroscience
as well where they
would actually
start predicting what neurons
does or what a group of neurons
does.
However, it doesn't explain,
necessarily, how that works.
So I think-- again, it goes
a little bit into philosophy.
It's a very important
thing that today, actually,
we don't get to do with AI.
However, in the
context of brain,
I think it's even more,
if you want, involved.
Because in a sense, what we're
trying to do with the AI,
in a certain sense, is to
create artificial intelligence.
That's why the word comes about.
And one of the big
questions about the brain
is what is intelligence
and how does it work.
If you can actually
create alternate versions
of intelligence, they
may not have anything
to do with how the brain works.
It still gives you a lot of
insights of what intelligence
could be, m how
intelligence could work,
or what are the limitations of
intelligence in certain areas
or others.
So I think, actually,
for neuroscience,
I would say there
is the data part,
there is the
prediction part that is
the same as with all sciences.
But in the specific problem
that you solve when you study
neuroscience-- or at least
one of the specific problems--
it's very, very close
to what the essence
of artificial intelligence is.
SETH SHOSTAK: Is that like
100 years ago, a little more
now, when they were trying
to build flying machines?
They tried at first
to imitate birds.
We'll have wings that
flap and so forth.
And that turned out not
to be the right approach.
Then they developed
something where
the wings don't move
at all, and you just
have a big propeller
in the front.
That's not the way--
very few of the birds in my
backyard have propellers,
and yet they could
make machines that
could fly pretty darn well.
But in the end, that
actually gave them insights
into how birds fly.
So are you talking about
something like that
where you build a machine that
can do some sort of thinking
process, but it doesn't work
at all like the human brain,
but that might be helpful?
MASSIMO MASCARO: If
you want, a jet engine,
it's not very similar to
a bird, even if it has
some kind of characteristics.
And a helicopter is completely
different than a bird.
However, the principle that
makes things fly apply.
And in a sense,
actually, if you want,
if you go to the very
bedrock of what flying is,
of how you generate
lift, you can actually
learn a lot from birds,
but you can learn also
a lot from helicopters
and jet engines.
So the idea here
is that our brain
is a way of doing intelligence.
And if you build another
way of doing intelligence,
maybe by completely
different means,
that may actually
still give you insights
about the bedrock of
what intelligence is
and how intelligence works.
Now, that said, I would
actually, just for the public,
say that the most successful
way of doing AI today
is deep learning.
And it's based on this
idea of neural networks.
A lot of people
that, as me, actually
have studied computational
neuroscience would say, oh,
neural networks are very
different from the brain.
And it's true.
They are very, very
different from the brain.
However, they have
a lot of analogies.
And those analogies actually
may give us a hint about, again,
that bedrock, about
what intelligence is
and how you can build
a system to learn.
Because at the end of
the day, intelligence
is a very fuzzy word.
But learning is something that
we are much more familiar with.
SETH SHOSTAK: Well,
Google did this experiment
in-- what, 2012?
I don't quite remember.
But they took 16,000 processors,
whatever it was, and they
let it loose on the internet,
and said, go find something.
And it found cats--
with very high
accuracy, by the way.
It found cats probably better
than any cat could find a cat.
I don't know.
And you can say, well,
that's not very useful.
But of course, the fact
that it could see things
on the internet-- so that's--
I guess that's machine learning.
But I think a lot of people
regard all these capabilities--
the fact that if you're
a go player, a poker
player, or a chess
player, there's
a machine that can beat you--
they regard them as a threat.
And should we be
looking at it that way?
AI, is that going
to take my job?
Is it going to
destroy my lifestyle?
What's your view?
MASSIMO MASCARO: My
personal view on this
is that I think, actually,
this is one of the greatest
opportunities of humanity.
So actually, I see it with
a very optimistic take.
I wouldn't work
on it if I wasn't
very optimistic about it.
I think, actually,
AI does have dangers
and does have questions
that we have to solve,
both in an applicative way--
so what are the constraints
where you want to apply AI--
and also from a
society perspective.
One thing we did at Google
is that we, very recently,
this summer, came out for--
we're the first company
to really do that--
come up with AI principles.
So we have actually
a code of conduct
in terms of where we
think AI could be applied,
and where it shouldn't,
and how it should
be applied when it's there.
Now, I personally don't think
that this kind of debate
can only be in the realm of
a corporation like Google.
Google, of course, has a lot
of investment and trust in AI,
but it's not the
only player here.
And I think, actually,
we should have
more of a societal
discussion about this.
SETH SHOSTAK: Is that
realistic, though?
99% of the world agrees, yes, we
have to have these boundaries,
whatever.
But the 1% that doesn't
believe in that,
or see some advantage
in themselves--
it sounds like there
might be some--
MASSIMO MASCARO: As the
prominent researcher
Nick Bostrom pointed out, AI
is intrinsically adversarial.
Because to your point,
it just takes 1%
to do the things
that it shouldn't do.
In a sense, this is not very
dissimilar to other kinds
of dangerous things that
we do, from nanotechnology
to biotechnology and
things like those.
But that, actually, is
why it's important to have
that societal discussion.
Because I don't think,
actually, any corporation--
any institution
itself on its own,
actually-- can really
put the right boundaries.
I think it's really--
it's becoming more and
more a humanity discussion.
And it's interesting, because we
are in a point of our history,
of our world, where
it seems, actually,
we're getting more fractured
instead of getting more united
as a global humanity.
And I see, actually,
danger in that.
On the upside, this could
be things that unite us.
Because to your point,
I think the majority
of the people on
Earth would agree
on a number of those things.
SETH SHOSTAK: Well,
finally, then, Massi,
it sounds like we're at a
stage in the development
of technology here
analogous to the invention
of the microscope,
the telescope.
These were tools that
allowed us to suddenly make
big discoveries.
It sounds like you're saying
that the 21st century--
in the first half of
the 21st century, we
might see not only the
detection of lots of planets,
but life on those planets,
maybe even intelligent life
on those plants.
And in medicine,
we might be curing
all sorts of diseases
that have stymied us
for hundreds of years.
And you wouldn't want
to rule out the tools.
You want to embrace those tools.
What's your advice
to young people
who are getting interested
in science and technology?
MASSIMO MASCARO:
So again, I think,
actually, it's an amazing time.
I've always been very passionate
about science and technology.
And like when I was young,
it used to be that--
unless you were really lucky
to go to a good university
and you have access to
libraries and journals,
you can't really
learn a lot of things.
Nowadays, young people
can go on YouTube
and watch like lessons of the
best professors in the best
universities for free.
And this actually
is great content.
You guys can play with
things, as I said.
It doesn't take a lot of money.
And by the way, there are
also educational programs.
If you guys are
interested, you can ping us
at Google Cloud where we can
actually give you credits.
But what I'm saying
is that it doesn't
take much to get-- and even
do serious science if you
are interested in it.
And I think, actually,
this actually democratizes
science enormously.
And I'm really hoping that
for the young people that
are listening to
us, they'll actually
get actually the passion for
science in the right way.
And now they have all the tools,
literally inside their laptop,
to go and do seriously it.
And I think, actually,
this is transformative.
This actually enlarges
the targeted population
for scientists by a number
of order of magnitude
from what it used to be.
SETH SHOSTAK: It sounds like
we're opening doors, big doors.
MASSIMO MASCARO: Yeah.
SETH SHOSTAK: I think people
will have the motivation
to walk through.
Massimo Mascaro, thanks so
very much for speaking with us.
I'm Seth Shostak.
Thank you for tuning in.